how do I describe you I was saying you
know entrepreneur Dalek Mandela's
Mavericks owner shark tank star you do
it on mark I don't know about that but
entrepreneur that one you know you and I
were talking earlier today on one of the
panels you made some really fascinating
points about innovation right now in
this country and and all that needs to
be done to encourage it to encourage
small businesses what do you think
overall is the most important thing for
new entrepreneurs right now just to go
after it I mean the thing about being an
entrepreneur is this it's just all to
you you know a lot of people like to
make excuses I don't have connections I
don't have money I don't have this but
you know if you find something that you
like to do or love to do be great at it
and see if you can turn it into a
business and worst case you're gonna
have fun doing what it is you love to do
in best case you can turn it into a
business I just don't pick on excuses I
just think if you really everybody has
that opportunity to go for it they just
got to do it well you know long as it's
a it's hard to get along right now for a
small business owner you're starting to
come over you're trying to come up with
an idea how do you get the capital to
start that bit first of all if you're
starting a business and you take out a
loan jerem [ __ ] right because you're
there's so many uncertainties involved
with starting a business yet the one
certainty that you will have to have is
paying back your loan and the bank
doesn't care about your business or
whoever you borrow from unless it's
family doesn't care about your business
you know and so it's just a complete
conflict so to whatever what's the small
business that entrepreneur 99% of small
businesses you can start with next to no
capital it's more about effort you know
small businesses don't fail for lack of
capital
they fail for lack of brains they fail
for lack of effort most people just
aren't willing to put in the time to
work smart I mean they they they go for
it in a lot of cases but they just don't
recognize how much works involved and
and if you do the preparation if you
know if you start a business you better
know your your industry and your company
better than anyone in the whole wide
world because you're competing and to
think that whoever it is you're
competing with is just gonna let you
come in and take their business
obviously that's naive and I think most
people don't recognize that if you're
going to compete with me and one of my
businesses you better realize that I'm
working
24 hours a day to kick your ass you know
a lot of companies right now are holding
on to their money they're holding on to
cash maybe they're doing some share
buyback but in general they're not
putting their capital to work right now
how and when did that start to change I
mean it's a reflection of a lot of
different things if if they're buying
back shares it means they don't see
anything in their own businesses that
they can invest in and if they don't see
anything in their own businesses that
they can invest in then it doesn't
matter if they're bringing back capital
from elsewhere and it doesn't matter
that they can talk all they want about
jobs but there's no good reason you know
to hire people because they don't have
places to put capital to work and I
think that's also a reflection of the
focus on Wall Street you know most of
times when we talk about putting
capillary to use we talk about public
companies you don't really see this as
an issue in private companies but with
public companies they get such a concern
with shareholder value and shareholder
returns that they lose sight of trying
to move the ball and to innovate and to
invest in R&D and I think that's hurt
our economy and I think that hurts the
company in the long term what does it
mean for growth you think we're gonna be
in this 2.5 percent 2% environment for a
while yeah and but I'm not I don't look
at that and say see there's something
wrong we're not doing something right I
look at that and say that's the new
normal that you know when companies have
their backs against well particularly
small to medium where there's a big part
of the growth for jobs we find new ways
to innovate we're innovators in this
country we don't just sit back and say
the only way we can solve problems is by
hiring people we go out there and you
hire smarter kids you hire smarter
people to write software to put things
in the cloud to find new solutions and
so we're turning into an economy that is
bifurcated there's those people who
write and control and define the
software and then there's those people
who work for the software someone who's
gone out and started a lot of businesses
including your own network CBS has just
purchased a minority stake in your
network what what do you think what is
their intention to do with that do you
think there's a chance they might buy
out the whole thing
who knows um but I think they're
recognizing that you know the reason we
took a network HDNet which was the first
all high definition TV that
grew it and then two years ago I
recognized that being HD obviously is
not enough and so I said out there in
the media landscape what opportunities
are there what what creates a unique
scenario that would be good for a
network and if you look at what's
happening with social media in
particular real-time social media is
very obvious and you guys know as well
as anybody real-time social media drives
real-time viewing on TV and live events
on TV Drive social media it's a very
symbiotic relationship and so with
excess TV we had been doing live events
as HDNet and we just amplified that so
in you know from concerts all over the
globe to the live interview shows to
live you know fights whatever type of
event that we can do live we want to do
it what people will tune in for live is
what differentiates television from the
internet you know the internet was
designed for everything but video and
television is designed specifically for
to deliver video and that's a huge
difference
the Internet's I mean when you think
about content now being so much
on-demand live obviously different
because you have to tune in specifically
for an event right but you know wouldn't
Gangnam style video right billion people
watch it you couldn't find any two
people who watched it and talked about
it at the same time it's just completely
different by the time you watch it on
YouTube you've already missed it you
know you've missed the conversation
YouTube's not about conversation on
demands not about conversation it's
about catching up it's about killing
time and vegetating watching the show
all day long
whereas watching this live hopefully
there's people online talking about how
Cubans an idiot or Cuban smart whatever
Trish knows our stuff or you know
whatever it may be but that's a that's
you know a holistic conversation that
happens in real time that drives that
creates a unique experience